[Music]
i know you live here in los angeles you
you live with a group of guys still is
that right four of us all together yeah
you guys live in is it like an animal
house kind of situation are you throwing
things out the window is pranking each
other yeah it's like animal house
without the motorcycle going down the
stairs right yeah i mean
and instead of drinking all night you're
all reading encyclopedias
get out of my room
just didn't get out of my room tonight's
gonna get crazy
we're gonna look at the axe encyclopedia
yeah
uh well uh and so it's all of you do you
guys have a nice easter did you all
celebrate together do you have a big ham
or something well not really i mean yeah
that's kind of what what's uh you know
left wanting a little bit is like i come
home to like a half a six inch subway in
the fridge and you know it's not really
the bountiful
easter that you know many would expect
well i happen to love subway and i think
you do as well
whenever i see a chance to make a little
extra
whatever we money
i'm just gonna send some sandwiches yeah
we're not getting money they're just
getting a gift card we're gonna get one
giant sandwich and i'm gonna have to
drive it over to you